Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Eccoci qui.
Nel bel mezzo della storia.
E di un evento epocale
che ricorderemo a lungo.
Per la seconda volta,
con la sensazione di esserne usciti.
Ricordate?
Ci sentivamo un po' così
anche alla fine dell'estate 2020:
il peggio sembrava essere passato,
e il calo dei decessi e dei contagi
ci aveva fatto ben sperare.
Io provo un po' quella sensazione
che si prova guardando al futuro.
Con la consapevolezza
che abbiamo trascorso una vicenda epocale:
tragica, ma anche unica.
E che se ne siamo usciti, caspita,
allora possiamo cambiare
il mondo, le nostre vite.
Possiamo migliorarle.
No?
Non avete anche voi questa percezione?
O forse,
forse prevarrà il nostro istinto
di conservazione,
la nostra voglia di tornare
al vecchio mondo, alle vecchie abitudini.
In fondo abbiamo un rapporto
con il progresso piuttosto complicato.
"Gli americani hanno bisogno del telefono:
ma noi no, non la Gran Bretagna.
Noi siamo pieni di Messengers Boy",
diceva nel 1878 Sir William Priest,
Chief Engineer del Servizio
Postale Britannico.
O ancora: "Il cavallo è qui per restare,
l'automobile è una novità,
è un capriccio":
si esprimeva così il presidente
della Michigan Savings Bank.
E lo diceva ad Horace Rackam,
l'avvocato di Henry Ford
che era stato invitato ad investire
nella nascente casa automobilistica.
"No, no, non investa:
l'automobile non durerà a lungo".
Ma non c'è bisogno di scomodare
i grandi scettici.
Mio padre, ad esempio,
a metà degli anni '80,
alla presentazione del Compact Disc
si spese in lunghissime arringhe
per decretarne il fallimento,
perché lui puntava tutto
su quell'impercettibile graffietto
che lo avrebbe reso
immediatamente inutilizzabile.
Naturalmente, dopo
una settimana arrivò a casa
con il primo CD
che io vidi nella mia vita.
Era Celentano, e lo stiamo
ancora ascoltando.
Ma il progresso non passa soltanto
attraverso gli oggetti, no?
Passa anche attraverso
i nostri comportamenti.
L'organizzazione della vita sociale.
Se vi faccio vedere
alcune immagini, che cosa pensate?
O ancora questa.
Ditemi:
chi di voi sta ancora vivendo
queste situazioni al lavoro,
alzi la mano.
Nessuno, o pochissimi? Una, due, nessuno.
Quattro, cinque, sei, sette, otto.
Insomma, magari aspettando
qualche minuto in più
sareste diventati tantissimi.
Chi pensa, invece, che appartengano
definitivamente al passato,
e che non vedremo mai più
nulla di tutto ciò?
Gente che corre a timbrare il cartellino:
chi pensa che siano
definitivamente abbandonate?
Quanti di voi?
Uno, due, tre, quattro: fortunatissimi.
Insomma, in ogni caso non possiamo negare
che abbiano segnato
le nostre esperienze lavorative, no?
Che i nostri modelli organizzativi
siano figli di quella ansia di controllo
e di quella sorta
di compravendita del tempo.
Eppure quel mondo, quelle relazioni,
non hanno portato
soltanto risultati positivi.
Vediamo insieme:
il 41% dei lavoratori
e lavoratrici italiani, ad esempio,
soffre di stress da lavoro correlato;
e sono 644.803 gli infortuni sul lavoro
denunciati all'Inail nel 2019,
di cui circa il 18% nel tragitto
di andata casa-lavoro.
Sì, perché in Italia abbiamo fretta,
noi vogliamo finire tutto alla svelta.
Insomma, l'Italia,
subito dopo Grecia e Estonia,
è il Paese dell'area euro
dove si lavorano più ore alla settimana,
in media 33:
sono tre ore in più del resto d'Europa.
In Italia c'è tanto da fare,
c'è lavoro per tutti.
Sicuri?
Nel 2019, la percentuale
di occupati in Italia è del 59%:
il 14% in meno della media europea.
Se parliamo di occupazione femminile,
il tasso medio europeo
di occupazione femminile
è prossimo al 70%:
quello italiano è del 50%.
Va bè, però se parliamo
di genere femminile
l'Italia ha sempre coltivato
il valore della famiglia, no?
Per noi la natalità
è un valore, è una missione.
Più o meno.
Nel 2019, il 73% delle dimissioni,
nel primo anno di vita del figlio,
ha riguardato donne;
di cui 21.000 perché non sono riuscite
a conciliare la vita e il lavoro.
E infine, la ciliegina sulla torta:
dal 2015 l'Italia è ultima,
nella classifica europea,
per nuove nascite.
Insomma, un quadro
non del tutto confortante.
Io ricordo che,
all'inizio degli anni 2000,
parlare di welfare,
di benessere al lavoro,
di work-life balance,
conciliazione e flessibilità
degli orari di lavoro,
era un tabù.
Era roba per pochi eletti,
per le multinazionali,
peraltro guardate sempre
con un po' di sospetto,
e senso di inferiorità,
da tante aziende italiane.
Il responsabile del personale
era una figura ritenuta superflua,
o necessaria solo in caso
di tagli all'organico.
Il direttore del personale
a cosa ci serve?
Spieghiamo noi alle persone,
come si lavora.
Ecco: il come si lavora,
e il come si sta al lavoro,
è sempre stata considerata
una questione meramente tecnica.
Qualcosa, però, in quegli anni
cominciava a muoversi,
e qualche azienda
cominciava a sperimentare
qualche misura di avanguardia.
Ne cito alcune tra tante: Telecom,
Microsoft, Tetrapack, San Pellegrino.
Nel 2005 San Pellegrino,
all'interno del progetto Primavera,
consentì a due suoi collaboratori
di lavorare a distanza.
Glielo permise perché voleva
provare a capire
che cosa succedesse agevolando
la conciliazione vita lavoro.
Quelle sperimentazioni furono le prime
che poi diedero alla luce
i primi accordi integrativi
sulla flessibilità degli orari di lavoro.
Il tema in quegli anni non era nuovo.
Il problema era che era
sempre stato affrontato
o in una logica e con
un approccio "filantropico" -
lo facciamo per senso del dovere,
per un senso di giustizia
nei confronti dei nostri dipendenti;
oppure in una logica avversariale:
se io vinco, tu perdi.
E quindi, l'azienda aveva la percezione
che tutelando, che facendo qualcosa
per i propri collaboratori,
questo si sarebbe tradotto
in un aggravio di costi;
mentre le persone che lavoravano,
e spesso il sindacato,
alla sola prospettiva
di una idea di business o di profitto,
immediatamente collegava una detrazione,
una riduzione delle proprie tutele.
Noi invece pensavamo
che esistessero soluzioni
che potevano combinare il vantaggio
per le aziende e anche per i lavoratori.
Qualcosa succede:
tra il 2010 e il 2014,
si comincia a lavorare
a un disegno di legge.
Che sfocerà, nel 2017, nella Legge 81
di cui voglio leggere
qualche passaggio con voi, a cui tengo.
Innanzitutto, la legge dice
che il lavoro agile ha un duplice scopo:
di incrementare la competitività,
e agevolare la conciliazione
dei tempi di vita e di lavoro;
e che la prestazione può essere eseguita
in parte all'interno
e in parte all'esterno
dei locali aziendali,
senza precisi vincoli di orario
e di luogo di lavoro.
È semplice.
Andate a leggere l'originale.
Non è una legge complicata:
obbliga? Vieta?
No, mette in sicurezza una possibilità,
la possibilità di scegliere
dove e quando lavorare.
Certo, a patto che quella decisione
sia il frutto dell'intesa
tra il datore di lavoro
e il proprio collaboratore.
Cosa succede, negli anni
immediatamente successivi?
Chi sperimenta il lavoro agile dice:
beh mi ha cambiato la vita.
Sembra banale,
ma non dover trascorrere
tre ore nel traffico,
anche per un solo giorno alla settimana,
è un vero sollievo.
Mi fa stare bene pensare
che riducendo i miei spostamenti
è come se avessi piantato dieci alberi.
Risparmio 50 km, 80 minuti al giorno.
Posso andare a fare una corsa
tra una riunione e l'altra.
Ho ridotto le spese per la palestra,
la baby sitter e la lavanderia.
Lavorare senza interruzioni,
con obiettivi chiari e scadenze stabilite,
ha migliorato la qualità
dei miei progetti,
la mia produttività, la concentrazione.
Nel 2019,
l'Osservatorio Smart Working
del Politecnico di Milano
calcola che gli smart worker sono 570.000,
il 20% in più rispetto al 2018.
È quasi fatta.
Io e Stefania Cazzarolli,
compagna di vita professionale,
raccogliamo tutti i dati
a nostra disposizione, le evidenze.
Abbiamo a disposizione un campione
di 30.000 rispondenti.
E andiamo a cercare
un editore per il nostro libro,
dal titolo:
"Smart working: l'unico modo
di lavorare possibile".
Ancora? Ancora smart working?
Ma è un tema assolutamente
inflazionato, no?
Ma ormai, tutti fanno smart working!
E poi è già stato detto tutto,
cosa aggiungereste?
Infine, vi suggerisco,
il titolo è un po' audace.
No, non è audace, non è audace.
È esattamente quello che sta succedendo.
La rivoluzione tecnologica
ci sta travolgendo,
sta investendo tutti i settori produttivi.
Ormai si fanno diagnosi,
si cura a distanza,
si producono macchine, si progettano,
si collaudano, si controllano a distanza,
non possiamo più evitare l'evidenza.
Noi volevamo spargere il verbo;
e spiegare al mondo,
nel più breve tempo possibile,
che quella era la strada,
unica, inevitabile:
la flessibilità.
La produttività non passa attraverso
le ore passate in ufficio,
ma attraverso il saper dare
degli obiettivi
e saperli comunicare
ai propri collaboratori.
Coinvolgerli.
Ingaggiarli.
Formarli.
E alla fine, fidandosi di loro.
Sì, fidandosi di loro.
Qualcuno si fidò di noi;
e poi alla fine, in realtà,
il nostro libro venne pubblicato -
con un titolo, ovviamente, diverso.
E siamo al 2019: tutti noi sappiamo
cosa accadde dopo.
No, noi col virus, la storia del virus
che è stato creato in laboratorio,
noi non c'entriamo eh.
Noi pensavamo che già il virus
del conservatorismo fosse pericolosissimo.
E però arriva il Covid.
E ci impone un nuovo modo di lavorare.
Non possiamo negare che, anche dal punto
di vista professionale-lavorativo,
qualcosa sia successo.
È vero: nonostante i disagi,
nonostante la difficoltà delle relazioni
e il dover lavorare a casa,
spesso dovendosi occupare,
contemporaneamente, dei nostri figli.
Ma incredibilmente, paradossalmente,
in quella costrizione abbiamo sperimentato
una nuova forma di libertà.
È bastato?
No!
Non sono bastati anni
di ricerche, di sperimentazioni,
di aziende illuminate, di libri.
Non è bastata neppure una pandemia.
Gli scettici del lavoro
"agile" ci circondano.
Il dibattito di questi giorni
è sotto gli occhi di tutti.
E quindi, che dire?
Be', che "non riporteremo
il dentifricio nel tubetto",
e cito un illustre collega
del Politecnico di Milano.
Perché sono successe, tra le tante,
tre cose importantissime:
le aziende hanno scoperto
che lo smart working conviene,
e piace anche a loro,
perché possono al contempo
essere più efficienti, produttive,
e far star bene i loro collaboratori.
I manager hanno scoperto
che possono fidarsi del loro team,
e possono verificare
il raggiungimento dei risultati
attraverso un criterio
che non siano le ore trascorse in ufficio.
E poi, soprattutto,
voi, noi, abbiamo scoperto
che un'altra vita è possibile.
E non siamo più disposti a rinunciare
a quelle che abbiamo scoperto essere
le nostre nuove priorità:
avere ritmi di vita sostenibili;
trascorrere più tempo
con le persone a cui teniamo;
e lavorare in modo efficace e produttivo.
Non siamo più disponibili
a cedere il nostro tempo senza uno scopo.
Ok, non possiamo dire che lo smart working
è la panacea di tutti i mali,
non lo stiamo dicendo.
Non dobbiamo.
Non funziona automaticamente,
non è perfetto:
dipende da come lo applichiamo.
Però, non possiamo più
negarne l'esistenza.
Come per il fuoco, la ruota,
il computer, l'elettricità,
è arrivato per cambiarci la vita.
Ma come con il fuoco, la ruota,
il computer, l'elettricità,
noi ci possiamo scottare,
possiamo perderci.
Possiamo fare del bene, o stare male.
Come li usiamo?
Per migliorarci la vita?
Dipende solo da noi,
e come useremo lo smart working
per migliorare la vita
dipende solo da noi.
Non possiamo più negarne l'esistenza;
ma imparare a usarlo sì,
per migliorare la nostra.
Insomma, è solo un altro
potentissimo strumento
che ci sta regalando
delle potentissime opportunità.
Usiamole.
Per il nostro bene.
Per il bene di chi ci circonda.
Per la nostra crescita, anche economica.
E per il benessere di questo pianeta
che, in fondo, ci sta solo ospitando.
Insomma, siamo nel bel mezzo
di un evento epocale.
E io provo, finalmente, la sensazione
di poter riprogettare il futuro.
Con entusiasmo,
e anche con tanta curiosità.
Non avete anche voi, questa percezione?
Grazie.
(Applausi)